WELCOME BACK TO THE BIG SATURDAY
SHOW.
WHAT HAPPENED TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S MESSAGE OF UNITY?
REMEMBER THAT?
THE PRESIDENT RAMPING UP ATTACKS
AGAINST SO-CALLED MODERATE
REPUBLICANS.
A PRIMETIME SPEECH EARLIER IN
THE WEEK LIKE THE U.S. MARINES
IN FRONT OF A DRAMATIC BACKDROP,
SOME CRITICS THING
AUTHORITARIAN.
>> MODERATE REPUBLICANS
REPRESENT EXTREMISM THAT
THREATENS THE VERY FOUNDATIONS
OF OUR REPUBLIC.
MODERATE FORCES DETERMINED TO
TAKE THIS COUNTRY BACKWARD AND
MODERATE REPUBLICANS TO DESTROY
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY.
MODERATE REPUBLICANS -- MODERATE
REPUBLICANS.
MAGA REPUBLICANS HAVE MADE THE
CHOICE.
THEY THRIVE ON CHAOS.
THEY LIVE NOT A LIGHT OF TRUTH
BUT THE SHADOW OF LIES.
GUY: OKAY.
THAT'S THE PRESIDENT WHO
CAMPAIGNED AS MR. UNITED, MR.
HEALER BUT NOW THE QUESTION IS,
IS HE TRYING TO CHANNEL FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP?
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" WRITING AN
EDITORIAL QUOTE JOE BIDEN HOLDS
A TRUMP VALLEY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS BECOME HIS
THOSE POLARIZING MIRROR IMAGE
AND HERE'S WHERE I START TO GET
CONFUSED BECAUSE THEY PLAYED THE
MONTAGE, VERY NEGATIVE
DESTROYING THE COUNTRY, ALL OF
THAT.
OUR COLLEAGUE PETER DOOCY
SHOUTED A QUESTION OF THE
PRESIDENT, HIS TEAM DIDN'T WANT
HIM TO ANSWER BUT HE DID AND HE
APPEARED TO WALK THAT BACK,
LET'S WATCH THIS TOGETHER.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, YOU CONSIDER
ALL TRUMP SUPPORTERS TO BE A
THREAT TO THE COUNTRY?
>> I DON'T CONSIDER A TRUMP
SUPPORTER -- THE COUNTRY.
I DO THINK ANYONE WHO CALLS FOR
THE USE OF VIOLENCE TO ATTEMPT
VIOLENCE REFUSE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
WHEN THE ELECTION HAS BEEN ONE.
CHANGING THE WAYS THE RULES
VOTE.
, DEMOCRACY.
EVERYTHING WE DO REST ON THE
PLATFORM OF DEMOCRACY.
PEOPLE VOTED FOR DONALD TRUMP TO
VOTE HIM OUT, THEY WANT VOTING
FOR ATTACK CALIFORNIA, THEY WENT
VOTING FOR REALLY OF ELECTION,
THEY WERE VOTING FOR THIS TO BE
PUT FORWARD.
GUY: OKAY WELL, RIGHT OUT OF THE
GATE, HE TALKED ABOUT VIOLENCE
BEING WRONG, PRESIDENT STILL NOT
CONDEMNING THE ASSASSINATION
PLOT AGAINST THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE NOT CONDEMN
A SERIES OF FIRE BOMBERS AGAINST
PRO-LIFE, I THINK WE'VE HEARD
MUCH ABOUT THAT.
YOU HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ELECTION
HAS BEEN ONE AND LOST.
I AGREE.
I ASSUME HE WILL ENDORSE BRYAN
CAN AGAINST STACEY ABRAMS FOR
OVERALL, HELP ME BECAUSE WE
HEARD WHAT HE SAID AND NOW HE'S
CLAIMING THAT'S NOT REALLY TRUE
OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS, 50 REMEMBER
WHAT WAS IN HIS SPEECH?
IS HE REALIZING IT'S ABOUT LOOK?
WHAT HAPPENED?
>> IS WHAT I THINK, I THINK THE
SPEECH WAS WRITTEN FOR HIM
BECAUSE THEY SAID PRESIDENT
BIDEN, YOU LOOK WEAK, WE NEED
YOU TO SHOW PEOPLE WHO STILL
HAVE GUSTO AND CAN GO AFTER
TRUMP BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SAYING
YOU WON'T RUN IN 2024 LOSING
STEAM, THAT WAS HIS MOMENT BUT
WHAT HE SAID TO PETER DOOCY IS
PALATABLE AND WHAT HE SAID TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WHAT HE SAID, HE DID NOT MAKE A
DELINEATION BETWEEN EXTREMISTS
WHO FORMED THE CAPITOL FOR
PEOPLE WHO RIDE IT FOR AN ENTIRE
SUMMER IN THE NAME OF GEORGE
FLOYD, HE DIDN'T MEAN EXTREMISTS
ON BOTH SIDES ARE FASCISTS OR
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO USE VIOLENCE
AS A POLITICAL TOOL OR WEAPON,
HE SAID MAGA REPUBLICANS.
EVERYBODY KNOWS WHAT THAT MEANS,
TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
WE CALL OURSELVES MAGA
REPUBLICANS.
THIS IS THE CLINTON DEPLORABLE
MOMENT, SUPPORT TRUMP IN THAT
WAY, NO DELINEATION AND NOW OF
COURSE THEY WILL WALK BACK
BECAUSE IT WASN'T A GOOD MOMENT
FOR HIM BUT WE KNOW WHAT HE
MEANT, IT'S CLEAR TO ANYONE WHO
WATCHED.
GUY: THE TWITTER ACCOUNT TWEETED
AFTER THE WALK BACK, ON WALK
BACK, MAYBE SCHEDULED TWEET WITH
A DOUBLED DOWN ON WHAT HE SAID
THURSDAY NIGHT.
TOMMI, IT WASN'T JUST GOING
AFTER JANUARY 6 RIOTERS WHICH
I'M ALL FOR, HE WAS LIMPING IN
AND CONFLATING THOSE PEOPLE,
PRO-LIFERS FOR EXAMPLE.
JEAN-PIERRE TALKING ABOUT
EXTREME POLICY ON TAX CUTS FOR
EXAMPLE, LUCAS.
IT'S A POLITICAL AGREEMENT AND
WHATEVER THE POLITICS, THE
CALCULATION I'M NOT SURE IS
PLAYING OUT THE WHITE HOUSE
CONTENT NOT SURE WHICH WAY YOU
LOOK AT THIS COMMUNICATION
STRATEGY STANDPOINT, ABLE TO
DELIVER PRIMETIME SPEECH THE
DARK ENEMIES OF REPUBLIC
ALTHOUGH DEMOCRACY WE ARE
REPUBLIC, HE GAVE THE CLERK
SPEECH NOT NECESSARILY CONTRAST
WITH WHAT HE SAID WHEN HE
ANSWERED PETER DOOCY IN THE
PRIMETIME SPEECH, HE SPOKE TO
THE HARDENED DEMOCRAT BASED
HANDS IN THE AIR ANGRY SHOUTING,
DARK SO THIS IS JOE BIDEN DOING
WHAT HE'S DONE HIS ENTIRE CAREER
AS A SKILLED POLITICAL LIFE.
I HAVE ANOTHER PART, THIS HAS
NOT BEEN ASKED ON MEDIA ABOUT
JOE BIDEN BUT THE TWO MARINES.
THE MARINES ATTACHED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE DETACHMENT AMENDED
OUT OF OUR NATIONS OLDEST
BARRACKS IN D.C., WHERE DID THE
MARINES COME FROM?
DID THEY COME UP WITH THE
PRESENCE DETACHMENT?
WHO'S IN CHARGE AND WHY AREN'T
THEY GOING ACROSS THE COURTYARD
TO SPEAK ABOUT WHY MARINES WERE
PUT IN THAT POSITION X WHILE A
LOT OF THE ARGUMENT IS
POLITICAL, LOOK AT THE OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVEN'T,
COMMUNICATIONS HE DID HIS JOB
AND SET IT UP FOR HIS BASE CAME
OUT THE NEXT DAY AND TRIED TO
WALK BACK AND I WASN'T SURPRISED
BECAUSE IT'S EFFECTIVE.
GUY: WITH THE MARINES, A BIG
CONTROVERSY, PRESIDENTS HAVE
SPOKEN MANY TIMES IN FRONT OF AN
BACKDROP MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY, THAT'S NOT NEW.
THIS WAS A CAMPAIGN SPEECH
ATTACKING OPPOSITION AND URGED
THE VOTE AND FOR THAT, THE
NETWORKS NOT COVER IT LIVE.
THAT WAS INTERESTING TO ME.
>> I THINK IT'S VERY TELLING
THAT IT WAS CAMPAIGN STYLE
SPEECH IN A SPEECH TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE IF HE
WAS SPEAKING TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, HE OFFENDED A LOT OF
PEOPLE, REGISTERED ARE OUT THERE
WHO DON'T WANT TO HEAR THERE ARE
BAD PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY REGISTER
FOR THIRD-PARTY, THAT'S JUST A
FACT HAND STRATEGY, I LEFT TO
GET NOBODY'S TAKE ABOUT THAT
SETTING, PEOPLE HAVE CALLED IT
SATANIC AND OTHER THINGS, DA